welcome to this video playing the Blitz
kicker from the Netherlands no name in
down I really thought he was a bullet
specialist isn't he yeah I mostly is but
now he's playing a 15 minute game very
suspicious let's see what happens okay
Kings Indian or groom fault
yeah he goes for the group out I'm not
sure no I want to play the h4 line again
I want to have some some the assam mix
they are not the same lines all the time
but it's a king's indian so going for my
age 3 set up ok is playing it
differently with c6 and d5 yeah that's
an interesting line for my purposes it's
oh that's not very common I think
normally they play d 6 after Bishop d3
especial d3 is really preventing 94 what
you normally want to do ok interesting
okay I'm going to keep it simple take
here and play queen bee three well this
night on g4 this cannot be good really
queen bee three dollars probably six
being played I don't see how he can
defend the five otherwise yeah come on
this looks quite simple h3 night h6
Bishop g5 here this looks quite quite
decent he cannot play em cannot play of
six now as I capture and age six Hanks
so it's not very comfortable choice here
for black it needs to move the Queen
basically young and now interesting i
can take why can play something else
mean the night maybe is coming to have
to f5 i wonder if i should just take and
play G for shutting out the night from
age 6 yeah maybe playing against this
piece the night on age 6
yeah what is he going to do knight c6 I
guess intending maybe night before
something like that now it's not easy
because he's got this really stupid
piece on age six maybe he will prepare
it prepare to get it back into play with
King edgy tonight GA that's at some
point could be a could be an idea but
how do I actually make any progress hmm
there's some way to ya nut before bit of
an annoyance I play kingly tube so that
after night b4 i can play nighty too
what I'm wondering about if Bishop f6
might be a move why it's not it's not
not crazy also how do i how do i improve
my position further night 26 could be an
idea or maybe really Bishop f6 yeah it
is not better in him take stakes should
be very nice for me and I don't
necessarily want to take on g7 I just
put it in them and improve behind that
you know I just thought Bishop e2 would
be fine
yeah okay I'll take them now this wasn't
a very successful idea but I'm still ok
but it didn't it didn't really help me
much getting the bishop traded
so do i play a three and before him to
gain more space yeah I guess so night
b-52 d6 would be a very nice improvement
I need to play this year now anyway
because Knight a5 was threatened so it
only makes sense in this context with
with a 3 before night b5 coming maybe
night a7 something that black can
consider here it's it's our passive but
it prevents 9 p-5 okay here there's also
Bishop b5
if you fight this Bishop c6 now
hmm yeah I'm not sure I didn't play this
perfectly for sure I mean perfectly is a
strong word anyway you you never do redo
that but there was certainly room for
improvement all this Bishop g5 f6 text
g7 this was probably not a good idea
maybe we should have six texts 27 could
probably just staff stayed on g5 yeah
well black does not have anything super
great but still it feels like I should
have gotten something better no check
ok
yeah night 2 D 3 would be nice but not
sure that I'm I wait wait a mode huh
just for a moment is some but what is
actually happening after night a for if
I just try to to get to be 6 here then
night takes d4 or what exactly is the
problem and I don't see it at the moment
Knight b6 might be 6 is very tricky 94
94 Bishop b5 Knight b6 looks great for
white probably overlooking something but
I don't really see a movie m yes but I
can take b6 really
no it's taking here first yeah but still
I can check here Bishop takes b5 and
night takes b6 and then rook a 6-yard
some miracle defense yeah oh it's always
funny if there is something like that
happening where you basically know that
nothing of that was planned beforehand
it's just happening yeah coincidentally
in the position okay let's see
Jim they don't really want to take on b5
this is not looking right if or you can
just take unfortunately when I don't
really have good squares maybe I need to
take don't really see her another move
came and we're let you go now rookie is
not ideally placed now maybe start with
that k about King sees King sees King c3
and look so normal
here a 5v six thus nights is 7i guess
and 94 maybe this looks okay whoopsie
ah'm can can maybe play looks yet I
thought I can take rook takes kinky to
takes King see one can you five in the
pawn see I thought I thought the pawns
would decide but maybe I'm miscounting
this yeah I should have thought about
this longer after Roxy aight i simply
don't have something else I need to take
you threatening Knight a5 TD to text xq
five
King before the end I get there I this
does not look good very stupid what I
did them now the king is so active okay
so let's not get too excited I can lose
the king I can move the king after Lucy
a that's very important Kingda to
walking be too because he's an opinion
and then probably that means that this
isn't even a good move rocks yet ok ok
ok very important that I have those King
moves 96 look c6 is probably losing yeah
now it's taking lots of time yeah I
think I'm threatening night takes is six
year at that king d 4 C 5 invading the a
pawn would be dangerous it is a critical
position yeah ok to be 2 or 2 d 2 yeah I
go here or should I look at this a bit
longer and let's just let's just go
ahead here
it seems better to me to stay in the
center well if everything else fails the
king is taking care of pin of the d5
pawn yeah I don't I really don't know if
you should play something like I was
just thinking king e5 but I don't really
believe that this should be a good end
game I can take and play a form mayor
okay this should be substantially better
for white with the pestle or the
upcoming passer here therefore of course
to prevent them the e5 expansion
check okay so he wants to go to f4 John
92 is very passive and dumb I go hear me
ok can really go King a form King III 96
and tense nights you for check but I
have knight Knight f3 chicken King
deform it should be quite good now
that's that's very good for white the
disposition
after the 96 I must play neither 3m Co
night c4s threatened like be five nights
ii for checking moose night x f5 as
embarrassing but Nadia three years just
good getting the King to deform ok so
he's preparing to after down I don't
understand it really I can well ok I
don't think he can do much anyway but be
five a six now it's a quite quite strong
isn't it if I go be five yeah yeah I can
even think about night be three just
stopping the King might be three
intending night c5
the immediate a6 salts are not bad
this also be 6 by the way attending a 6
not bad
night be three this may be night c 8 so
I'm a 6 text takes Knight c8 and
probably age from h5 is a good move
anyway but King see if the Kings if I
always have a 6 can be six
takes cheese
yeah this should really win i have not
be five as one i have not be five to
support the a7 pond when it comes to a
seven yeah something like night c 8 9
p-5 check yeah or hear the check check
and a 7 now keen to deform this should
be should end in a zoosk way with this
is getting there getting the square this
side didn't really appreciate oops oh
that's not good and especially g6 I if I
take
have I really spotted this what a shame
wow it was really a totally winning
night end game and as I overlooked age 5
p.m.
check
there's some way to do man if you just
get this pawn here some way to dominate
this an idol something like that i don't
i don't see any any any idea as very
mean then that applied will is really
stupidly
hm so I shouldn't push the apron so
quickly I was I simdi of a look at age
five very bad technical play
I can take g 6 h two check check on D
694 I'm coming too I'm just stopping the
Pawn check
game bro yeah that's a that's really a
bit bit annoying because was better the
whole game and then got this winning end
game especially the rock trade is
totally really insane as it that quite
obviously is lost but I didn't I didn't
I didn't mean it I didn't win this is
the easiest g5 and black resins okay
check check always frustrating that you
sometimes are just a total idiot yes
that's really easy yeah okay wow this
this still should win and be five I just
need to and just need to avoid Jack
White this King ever want its it's it's
it's over yeah I overlooked h5 as simple
as that it was the wrong calculation
check oops sorry wrong button yeah I
know h5 is a draw probably king f4 is
still still interesting
computer gives it as a draw yeah
probably because this is a draw yeah i
mean okay i missed very simple wins what
is quite instructive though is that he
absolutely should never play in night a
7 I mean maybe maybe there is a tactical
justification okay okay I'll play b5 are
the Weizmann okay but this is just a
just a lost endgame a very bad end game
yeah 35 there is g5 so if I've wasn't
playable at all I was more thinking
about this one but check check you know
this sign it's a disaster really yeah
disappointing i have simply overlooked
age 5 and this is some bad play alright
thanks for watching